Dear Bill.
Today is February 13th,
I came to this black wall again to see and touch your name.
And as I do,
I'm wondering if anyone ever stops to realize that next to your name on this
black wall
is your mother's heart
heartbroken.
15 years ago today
when you lost your life in Vietnam.
And as I look at your name,
William are stocks.
I think of how many,
many times I used to wonder how scared and homesick you must have been in that
strange country called Vietnam,
NDF and how it might've changed you
for you were the most happy go lucky kid in the world,
hardly ever sad around happy.
And until the day I die,
I will see you as you laughed at me even when I was very mad at you.
And the next thing I knew
we were laughing together.
But on this past new year's Day,
I had my answer.
I talked by phone to a friend of yours from Michigan who spent your last
Christmas in the last four months of your life with you.
Jim told me how you died.
Yeah,
but he was there.
And saw the helicopter crash.
Yeah.
He told me how you had flown your quota and it not been scheduled to fly that
day.
How the regular pie that was unable to fly and had been replaced by someone with
less experience,
how they did not know the exact cause of the crash,
how it was either hit by enemy fire or that they hit a pole or something unknown
how the blades went through the chopper
and hit you
power.
You lived about a half hour,
but we're unconscious and therefore did not suffer.
He said how your jobs were like sitting ducks.
They would send you men out to draw the enemy into the open and then they would
send in the big guns and planes to take over.
Meantime,
death came to so many of you.
He told me how after a while over there instead of a yellow streak,
the men got a mean streak down their backs
each day the street got bigger than the men became meaner.
Everyone but you bill.
He said,
how you stayed the same happy go lucky guy that you were when you arrived in
Vietnam.
How are your warmth and friendliness drew the guys to you?
How your lieutenant gave you the nickname of spanky and soon your group,
Jim included.
We're all known,
has Spanky's gang.
How when you died it made it so much harder on them for you.
Were there moral support?
Can he said how you of all people
should never have been the one to die?
Yeah.
Oh God.
How it hurts to write this,
but I must face it and then put it to rest.
I know that after Jim talked to me,
he must've relived it all over again and suffered.
So
before I hung up the phone I told Jim I loved him.
Love him for just being your close friend and for sharing the last days of your
life with you
and for being there with you when you died,
how lucky you were to have him for a friend,
like how lucky he was to have had you.
Later that same day I received a phone call from a mother in billings,
Montana.
She had lost her daughter,
her only child a year ago.
She needed someone to talk to for no one would let her talk about the tragedy.
She said she had seen me on television on New Year's Eve.
After the Christmas letter I wrote to you and left at this memorial had drawn
newspaper and television attention.
She said she had been thinking about me all day and just had to talk to me.
She talked to me of her pain and seemingly needed me to help her with it.
I cried with this heartbroken mother and after I hung up the phone I laid my
head down and cried as hard for her.
Here was a mother calling me for help with her pain over the loss of her child,
a grown daughter,
and as I sobbed I thought,
how can I help her with her pain when I have never completely been able to cope
with my own?
They tell me the letters I write to you and leave here at this memorial are
waking others up to the fact that there is still much pain left after all these
years from the Vietnam War.
But this I know
I would rather to have had you for 21 years and all the pain that goes with
losing you
the never to have had you at all.
Mom
Grand.
That was a letter written by Mrs Eleanor when Bish Mother of Sergeant William R
spanky stocks from Glen Burnie,
Maryland
who was killed in action in a helicopter crash in Vietnam on February 13th,
that letter was one of many that she has written and places beneath panel 32
where his name is etched into the Vietnam memorial wall along with more than
58,000 other names
of our fallen heroes.
And I read an interview with Mrs [inaudible] from 1990
and in that interview she said,
when my son died,
I wrote my pledge.
I said,
I will not now or ever let people forget.
So
for Mrs when Bish
and her son Bill spanky stocks
during this holiday season,
let us all remember,
remember the service and supreme sacrifice of so many
and also
let us learn some important lessons from Mrs. Wynn Besch and from her son.
From Mrs [inaudible],
we learn to be thankful for what we have had.
Yeah.
Even if it is lost and even if that loss causes pain,
still
be thankful.
And from her son Bill,
we can learn that even in the face of horror and deaf,
we can maintain our warmth and our friendliness and that that warmth and
friendliness can guide and support others
can help bolster the spirit of those around you
by simply
smiling.
So
as we celebrate the holidays,
yeah.
Let us be thankful for what we have.
And like Sergeant William,
Bill spanky stocks,
keep smiling,
have a merry Christmas
and a happy new year.